joining us now with more reaction the
host of war stories Colonel Oliver North
is with us Colonel when you see that
Russia pulled out their ships
they're obviously anticipating a strike
Moscow's threats of shooting America
missiles out of the sky do you believe
that's a possibility and will we be
prepared for that
Sean thirty two years ago tonight we
were doing the final target list for the
strike on Libya and so what I did is I
went through the targets that are
publicly known are not just ours that
everybody knows what we would have to do
in the sequence we'd have to do it it's
on that map that I sent you the first
hits got to be at the Syrian sa 300
necessay 400 air defense sites the air
base south south of Latakia at sea port
and Syria's Alphaeus air base near
Palmyra because you have to take out
those air defenses to make multiple
strikes possible second you hit the
bottle outside civil military airport
and the Aleppo Airport because those are
their primary air links for the outside
world you take out the fuel farms the
towers the revetment the helo and
fixed-wing aircraft assets that assad
has been using to deliver those chemical
weapons and that'll stop it third you
take out and if you have to your mind
the Latakia and bun es Mediterranean Sea
ports take out the piers material
handling equipment and the road links
because you're punishing him for using
these weapons he can't get replacements
in if that's gone the Russian ships as
you point out did sortie from their base
at tardes but the pipelines and tanker
trucks lined up outside those that base
are fair game do you have any doubt
colonel commanded control nodes in
Damascus in Assad's presidential palace
in other words just like we did with
Gaddafi target Assad and the Syrians and
Russians by the way are billeted
separately at those military bases
around Damascus so we know which is
which Russians stay home Syrians go away
for good measure created the runway to
outright military airfield which was hit
last April just to make sure he can't
use it again we didn't crater it all we
did was take out the stuff on the top
his Moscow line colonel
trying to blame the rebels we're going
to talk to mr. Hoffman in just a second
here and he says they don't have the
means meaning the rebels to deliver
those weapons
here's how you know that the Russians
are lying the lips are moving they're
lied about using chemical weapons
against one of their former spies inside
the Great Britain they're liars hasn't
changed all right safe home colonel and
by the way one of those planes behind
Colonel North actually wants me colonel
north and the great one Mark Levin were
in that plane in the worst plane ride
we've ever had ever all right safe home
and war stories don't forget Saturday
night a p.m. Fox Business Network you
don't want to miss it